I sent him the demo of what we had
started called waiting room and when I
got off the plane in Minneapolis we're
going through the airport his his
bodyguard was there and he had this
phone he's like the artist wants to
speak to you again
I was like okay so he puts me on the
cell phone he goes I had to rewrite the
song and I was like okay he's like but I
think you're gonna like it and so we get
to the studio understandably Park it was
there and he's super sweet and like his
around is there an instant sort of
chemistry in the sense that you both
speak the same language musically No
yeah a whole nother planet level I went
in the booth and I did not come out for
like eight hours I'd like can I get a
water like it was like and he would be
like sitting at the desk and he just
literally won like harmony after another
he would just feed it to me and I would
have to like spit it back out and I was
it was scared I was so scared because
I'm not even that good of a singer Jim
I'm saying like I I don't know I think
your songs are hard to sing I don't
think those are even anything
technically that's a singer I'm like I
kind of have my style or whatever but
it's not like I have a big Ranger you
know ii mean i i I can sing in tune and
I can hear notes but but he's like a I
mean he's just like a genius Jim sang
he's and he's he's like oh I haven't
done these kind of these kind of like
harmonies since like Wendy and Lisa and
I'm just sitting there going is this
happening to me right now incredible